Starship Troopers was a movie I watched
when I was eight years old and I thought
it was a pretty cool sci-fi movie but
what I didn't know was that it was one
of the most misunderstood movies ever my
eight-year-old self will be completely
surprised starship troopers a dumb space
war movie Starship Troopers a brilliant
satire of military propaganda Starship
Troopers a movie that misunderstood the
novel he was partying and then got
misunderstood for what it was parroting
Starship Troopers war is stored in the
balls hello everybody it shook me lately
there's been a lot more articles talking
about Starship Troopers as in the light
of we got it all wrong how could we have
been so blind you're all a bunch of
fools you do not understand it was a
joke Wow your mom maybe in retrospect
it's easy to point out how overly the
top the satire is but looking back at
reviews at the time it seems like a lot
of people just didn't get it the exact
words are the text but do you understand
it believe it so what really is being
misunderstood here and why let's
investigate would you like to know more
[Music]
hold it
citizen rule people making a better
tomorrow
[Music]
the movie starts off with these military
propaganda films and it's really during
these times that it should have been
obvious they're basically spelling out
for us it's the story follows John Rico
and Carmen Ibanez I mean just a look at
these two these characters look like
they came straight out of a Beverly
Hills TV show and that's the point
rumor has is that the director purposely
selected these actors to just look that
part to make war look attractive and all
these pretty people are fighting this
idea is also reinforced through just how
the film looks it's not your ordinary
gritty alien type of sci-fi it's it
looks and it's shot like a high school
rom-com from the 90s during one of their
final classes the teacher is explaining
why only what's called citizens are
allowed to vote why are only citizens
allowed to vote but we're not really
listening because we're distracted by
the flirting and playfulness between
Rico and his girlfriend they've seen as
a perfect example on how this movie
could get over people's head despite at
times feeding the message over you with
a stick when school is over they sign up
for their military duty to become
citizens but before breaking apart they
make a promise to stay together let's
make Rico joins the infantry force
Ibanez joins to Starfleet during one of
Rico's training exercises he pushes it
too far and an accident occurs
[Music]
pretty sure he's dead bait pretty sure
to break down the story to the bare
minimal when Osiris gets destroyed in an
alien attack Buenos Aires has been
[Music]
Ibanez ends up with another guy she
meets a Starfleet and Rico ends up with
another girl that was all over him
during high school during the attack of
alien space planet she then dies very
tragic along with Ibanez new boyfriend
who gets his brain sucked out we don't
need to show that honestly it's pretty
gross the brain bug gets captured and
since it controls all the other bugs the
battle has been won and they reached a
amazing conclusion that
[Music]
[Applause]
it's afraid it's afraid everybody who
would have thought so there they are
together back again just like in the
beginning but they're really not with
who they want to be it's more of a well
I guess our boyfriend/girlfriend died so
here we are and the message of the
stories and all we won the war is over
it's we won but we must keep fighting
any banas and Rico is the figurehead of
this next generations of Fighters just
like it will just keep going and keep
going when the movie came out it got
terrible reviews and ratings in America
we were accused by the Washington Post
of being neo-nazis the director says
also pointing out how in England they
seem to have understand the joke this
movie is meant to be an exaggeration of
America there we are always right
attitude to war which is probably why it
flopped in the US and was a hit
everywhere else in the world one of the
reviews that I could found that gave it
two stars said this want to know more
yes I did I was particularly intrigued
by the way the bugs had evolved organic
launching pods that could spit their
spores into space and could also fire
big gobs of unidentified fury matter at
the attacking spaceships since they have
no technology these abilities must have
evolved along Darwinian lines to say
this severely tested theory of evolution
is putting it mildly this is the point
of the film if you look at the attack of
Buenos Aires first of all that guy is
not from Buenos Aires you see the
footage of the meteor you see the fires
you see all the things you don't see any
bugs you don't see any evidence of an
actual attack the Society of Starship
Troopers is completely dependent on war
to function they and therefore they need
an enemy to function and for example
when the meteor attacks Rico is more
sure than ever that he wants to fight
against the bug when in reality it was
probably just a regular meteor a movie
like this will probably never exist
today because of how carefully edit
and selected they are by the studios and
I do think it's a fantastic film and if
you haven't seen it I definitely
recommend watching it and and maybe it's
time for a rewatch as well but there's
another side of the story that seemed a
lot of times untold the book while 99%
of movies based off novels that tend to
be as close as possible to resemble its
source material to appease fans or the
author this films basically pulls down
its pants and unloads their biggest dump
it could possibly give on this novel the
only thing the movie really borrows from
the novel list of bugs and the names of
the characters in the novel in fact
there's barely any action in it there's
only really one fight and the director
of the filming said said that I stopped
after two chapters because it was so
boring it is really quite a bad book I
asked Edie newmeyer to tell me the story
because I just couldn't read the thing
this kind of annoys me or anyone being a
fan of the novel really because despite
me maybe not agreeing with everything
the novel says it has a lot of
interesting things to say it's basically
a parody that got misunderstood and it
still misunderstood what he was trying
to parody so are we back at this source
material I've never seen anything like
this it's so weird it's so confusing
Highland the author's politics are
difficult to point to because a lot of
times he just seemed to enjoy playing
around with ideas there without a doubt
provocative but that's what make this a
classic novel Heinlein wrote Starship
Troopers because he thought America was
getting soft and the bugs is flat-out a
description of a communist society if
you're looking for an epic space sci-fi
battle of man between bugs reading this
you'll definitely be disappointed here's
some themes that was discussed in the
novel when the teacher in the beginning
scene that talks about civic duty he
discusses that anything that is given to
you has no inherent value if it's given
for free which is why only what is known
as citizens is allowed to vote you could
give someone an award without having
them to work for it but it wouldn't be
worth the same to that person
hyaline felt the same about voting it
shouldn't just be handed down to you
democracy is something we fought for but
you won't appreciate it if it's handed
down for free I'm not saying I endorse
his idea of having to perform military
service to vote but seeing how younger
people are less and less inclined to
vote pokemons going to the polls isn't
really making anyone go to the polls the
teacher also discusses violence and
importance of it in this society
something given has no value look when
you vote you are exercising political
authority you're using force and force
my friends is violence when the movie
depicts violence as the ultimate source
of conflict solver you live because it's
silly it's dumb and it's over-the-top
but I wonder what the city fathers of
Hiroshi would say about that you they
probably wouldn't say anything
Hiroshi mo was destroyed correct what
the [ __ ] actually why laughing we're
turning a blind eye into history and
maybe then it's not so funny punishment
is a very long important part of the
novel it explains House punishment is
vital to this society that we learned
right and wrong from punishment man has
no moral instinct he is not born with
moral sense you were not born with it I
was not and a puppy has none we acquire
moral sense when we do through training
experience and hard sweat of the mind
last but not least the novel makes a
very long case for why you should join
the military it feels like Heinlein
wrote this to inspire young people and
that Rico's character growth going from
a boy to a man is a reflection of his
own the novel makes a case that veterans
should run society because they know
what's best for mankind they can make
decisions that are tough where one
person gets to suffer for the better of
the masses while in today in our society
we're hyper focused on individuals the
outcry of one person could have a
massive effect on everyone
EF I directed the Department of Defense
and Pentagon to immediately begin the
process necessary to establish a space
force as the sixth branch of the Armed
Forces we must have American dominance
in space a lot of us look at war today
as something that we moved away from we
avoid it because we know better now but
do we really the society and starship
troopers needed war for its society to
function but within its context it might
even be justifying but within ours maybe
not I hope you guys enjoy this video
leave a like if you did and I'll see you
with another one tomorrow
goodbye